situé à proximité de la mer est
traversée par le fleuve gotha alpes la
ville de göteborg a une histoire et
l'économie étroitement liées à l'eau
c'est donc tout naturel citons ici que
le réseau de transport en commun déjà
composée de tramway et d'autobus offre
aussi le service de bateaux
voici donc au milieu du plus grand port
de scandinavie la navette fluviale de
göteborg sept jours sur sept du matin au
soir
ces six traversier bleu et blanc relie
la rive nord à la rive sud du gothard
ils peuvent accueillir 300 passagers et
80 vélos en même temps arrivée dans le
paysage il ya 25 ans avec les nouveaux
développements au bord de l'eau
aujourd'hui les bateaux sont bien utiles
beaucoup de gens doivent traverser le
fleuve et nous voulons être le plus
écologique possible explique le patron
de va ce trafic
la société de transport de cette ville
de 550 mille habitants les bateaux
ajoutent ils sont de plus en plus
populaire et effectivement ce vendredi
de la fin où il y avait foule à l'heure
de pointe
l'an dernier 2 millions 400 mille
passagers ont pris le bateau avec une
moyenne chaque jour de semaine de 8000
personnes
deux des bateaux sont simplement
utilisées pour faire l'aller retour de
la rive nord à la rive sud sans arrêt il
passe toutes les 8 minutes et la
traversée est gratuite
les quatre autres bateaux propriété d'un
partenaire privé font quant à eux six
arrêts des deux côtés du fleuve
le billet coûte environ 4 dollars et
donne aussi accès à tout le réseau de
transport en commun de la ville ceux qui
ont une carte mensuelle équivalente à la
carte opus à montréal peuvent l'utiliser
à bord de chaque navette on trouve des
dizaines de sièges pour se reposer et un
accès au wifi certaines aussi un pont
extérieur pour jouer au touriste par
beau temps le taux de satisfaction des
usagers seraient 2 99%
parce que les bateaux naviguent 12 mois
par année
l'hiver il faut le dire est quand même
moins dur à göteborg qu'à montréal et le
fleuve ne gèlent jamais complètement
les navettes sont exploités par le
partenaire privé mais la société de
transport admet que le service n'est pas
rentable
les bateaux coûte 10 millions de dollars
par année incluant les infrastructures
notre transport en commun est
déficitaire
l'agglomération paix pour la moitié des
coûts et nous pour l'autre moitié
et ça vaut aussi pour les navettes des
pâtes
trouvera les bateaux coûte cher ajoute
le porte-parole de la ville
il faut calculer les sens et la main
d'oeuvre en suède il faut deux ou trois
employés par bateaux alors göteborg qui
a besoin de plus de lien entre ces rives
n'est pas certain de vouloir plus de
navettes et songe même un téléphérique
sauf que la ville est contente d'avoir
le service actuel les bateaux compte
pour seulement 1 % des déplacements
transports en commun mais c'est un
pourcentage de moins sur les routes est
un atout pour les piétons et les
cyclistes
ça met de la vie sur notre fleuve et on
peut pas s'en passer conclut créerions
seul morial limitera tel göteborg
la balle est dans le camp des élus